AD
Ruju, a girl from Nairn, a world where humans and androids called Nairn coexist, is
tasked with carrying out a government mission with only her buddy.
Our work is a top secret that no one should know.Even if we
hear about our mission,
we must stop the Immortals, the Legacy of Immortality.They
are beings with potential that surpasses humanity.Why are they targeting us?  We
only do what we are told to do.A wedge is firmly driven into our consciousness.We
must not harm humans.We
must obey the orders of humans.Tell me, I
don't know what is the difference between us and humans.I'm doing something wrong.
No, what are we fighting for?
[Music]
code name Metal Luzil's secret code
Eve Your very existence has a meaning
Can you believe in me? Ah, you
dream of a world where humans can live together.  What kind of
future do you choose? Freedom is yours to choose. The
guardians of the order of this world. Humans and Ann's wish to protect their freedom.
Don't give up. The future of humans and Neann is
entrusted to them.
Metallic
[Music]
Ruju